[Music]
happy November everybody Welcome to the
data science hangout I actually just
shared our hundred data science hangout
recording to YouTube yesterday and made
me realize that we never actually
celebrated that so thank you all for
being here and making this space what it
is I can't believe we're already over a
hundred uh data science Hangouts if this
is your first time joining us hi so nice
to meet you I'm Rachel I lead customer
marketing at posit this is our open
space to chat about data Science
Leadership questions you're facing and
getting to hear about what's going on in
the world of data across different
Industries so we're here every Thursday
at the same time same place so if you're
watching this recording on YouTube later
and you want to join us live you can use
the link below to add it to your
calendar but at the hangout we're all
dedicated to making this a welcoming
environment for everybody love to hear
from everyone no matter your years of
experience your titles industry or even
the languages that you work
in it's totally okay to just listen in
here and I say if you're out walking the
dog maybe you're at lunch it's okay to
just listen in but there's also three
ways to jump in and ask questions or add
your per own perspective so you can
raise your hand on zoom and I'll keep an
eye out here you can put questions in
the zoom chat and just put a little star
next to it if it's something you want me
to read out loud and said and then
lastly we have a slido link where you
can ask questions anonymously too and
thank you Curtis for sharing that there
in the
chat uh sometimes I forget to say this
but if anybody is hiring feel free to
share any open roles in the chat as well
that's definitely not spammy at all to
me I think it's great to share those
those jobs in the chat too um but with
that I am so excited to introduce my
co-host for today David Sloter David is
data science senior program manager at
The Institute of nuclear power
operations and David I'd love to have
you just introduce yourself a bit and
share a little bit about your role but
also something you like to do outside of
work
too sure thank you Rachel and uh good
morning good afternoon good evening
depending on where you are I'm really
excited to be here I've got two
disclaimers though I have to I have to
start off with right um so number one I
just want to you know publicly say I'm
here to represent my own opinion I am uh
not here to represent my employer uh
Institute of nuclear power operations or
the broader nuclear industry you know of
course I'm going to talk about them to
give the conversation some context but
this is purely my opinion and then the
second piece is that I I really need to
make sure everyone knows that uh
anything I talk about today is
um it's not just my work so I I work as
part of a broader team and you know that
the team has worked so hard to build out
data science at impo you know I work
with a a bunch of smart passionate
people and it's just really uh important
that they they get a lot of credit too
here so um with that said uh my name is
David Sloter I'm a data scientist here
at Ino I've been um at PO for um almost
12 years now only about two years in the
data science space about 10 years in uh
the it space here at
Ino and um you know it's it's a really
interesting company and um I didn't know
anything about Ino until I started to to
work here so so maybe I'll kind of give
you a briefer on on what we are and what
we do so Ino is an independent nonprofit
that is funded uh by our members and our
members are the nuclear power industry
so uh within the US I think we have 54
nuclear power stations uh and they all
kind of you know pay us a member-based
fee uh to perform our service and now
our service is that we uh set and assess
safety and reliability standards for the
nuclear power industry so um we set
these standards uh we send out
evaluation teams to actually kind of uh
determine how well the different
stations are adhering to these standards
we uh you know kind of give them a score
at the very end of that that and um you
know that we we do that on on a regular
Cadence so we do that along with also uh
kind of facilitating the the sharing of
knowledge across stations which is is
really interesting in an industry where
you have different companies competing
together um but then also sharing
information with an independent uh
organization that allows them to you
know kind of share share what they've
learned so that uh we're all able to
learn from each other's uh experiences
mistakes challenges that sort of thing
um I've been doing you know kind of data
science for for about two years now um
before that I worked in it but my U my
background is that my bachelors you can
call my background is in humanistic
psychology which is you know kind of the
the most qualitative thing that you
could do so it's been been a fun road to
to figure out how I got
here um you know outside of work I like
to do a lot of things uh I like I like
to read I like to laugh and I like to
Trav so this past weekend I was able to
indulge all three you know posit cont
for this year was in Chicago and it was
the first time I had been to Chicago
with any chance to explore it so I I I
got back home and I told my wife Katie
hey we need to go to Chicago so we went
to Chicago this past weekend and we saw
you know our favorite comedian we went
to go see some improv we found kind of a
a punk bookstore which was a whole lot
of fun um and we got to do just a lot of
a lot of wandering around the city so it
was a it was an awesome trip and you
know I at this point kind of recommend
Chicago to anyone especially if it's the
weekend before Halloween because then
you just get right around on the the El
Train and watch everyone's uh
costumes that's awesome I know there
were a few people from posit who have
been thinking about moving there after
going for paa conference too I see why
yeah I see George asked who did you see
perform Maria Bamford she's my favorite
comedian number two is Kyle canine um
well David thanks so much for the intro
and and sharing a little bit about your
background there I know when we were
chatting you shared some more info on
how you had previously worked in it as
well and so I was just curious to kick
off the the conversation with that
because it's something that comes up
quite a bit in the space but having
moved from it to data science I know you
have probably pretty unique perspectives
on both sides um what would you
recommend to some of us who might be
struggling to communicate across those
lines that's a good uh question and you
know I think a challenge that I I hear
in the Hangouts and then also just kind
of conversations I've had with other
people you know um to me a lot of the a
lot of times you have these challenges
and it really just kind of boils down to
to building a good relationship you know
so um that can can pan out in a lot of
different ways and it's really dependent
on your organization and I think how
it's how it's set up and just the you
know kind of the general size of it
the way that we did it was um you know
we kind of built data science you know
not quite from scratch but uh we had one
organization at Ino that did some sort
of kind of D data sciency work and then
our senior leadership team kind of
identified it as a as a strategic
priority for the company to actually
build out that capability so then there
was a lot of emphasis and a lot of focus
on it and that was um right after I had
moved into the data science organization
so we um we knew that you know data
science and it needed to work together
because I mean every single project that
we work on has an IT component to it um
so some of what we did is um we started
having um leadership meetings between
data Science Leadership and it
leadership on some sort of regular
Cadence just to kind of talk about uh
what the road maps look like what
projects on are on the horizon what
challenges there might be and just kind
of putting everything out in the open as
much as you can just to have those
conversations um you know on on a more
personal level I think it's really
important for the two groups to kind of
um learn more about what each group does
you know so sit down with a network
engineer and and understand why you know
they they might be a little cautious
about opening up all of uh you know
opening up their infrastructure to all
of the packages on a repo or um you know
having a network engineer sit down with
a data scientist and understand why
that's a challenge for
them it it really to me just kind of
comes down to to having having
conversations and being uh open and
honest and transparent and um figuring
out a way to move forward together
that's great H how did you actually
first start those conversations I think
you said it was at the senior leadership
level but was there something that kind
of drove those initial
conversations well so um data science
kind of became an emphasis for info
because the way that we were doing
business was changing so we um go and
evaluate stations every two years that's
kind of been the regular Cadence for for
about 30 years and but a lot can happen
in between those those twoe assessments
right so we understood that we needed to
get into more of a kind of a of a
continuous monitoring sort of fashion
and the only way that we can do that
because we don't want to go out and
evaluate more often it's a really costly
thing to set up an evaluation team and
send it to a station so um instead it it
meant that we needed to figure out a way
to use the data that we have to you know
do some modeling some analysis and try
to kind of understand what their quote
unquote performance looks like in
between those
evaluations um so that was you know kind
of where it landed at at a strategic
level and then it you know kind of
became became our job to actually
Implement that and um you
know having having recently it was it
was real lucky having moved right from
from it to data science and being able
to kind of bring that perspective to
both sides um you know I think put us in
in a really good situation but I know
that's kind of a rare situation to be in
too
so you know I think yeah just just kind
of like sitting sitting down you know
putting your chairs in a circle and
saying what's what's going on what can
we work on how do we how do we figure
this all out together is it's just kind
of the way right way to start yeah thank
you uh Russ I see you asked a question
in the chat do you want to jump in here
yeah thank you
um I have a master's in counseling I
love humanistic psychology I could
talked about that all day how does that
help you in data science if so can you
say something about
that I I I thought about that you know
kind of in preparation for that talk and
the more that I thought about it the
more the more kind of threads that I
could see just just because you know a a
lot of data science and a lot of working
in an organization in general is is kind
of working on relationships and
communication
and actually you know um actively
listening you know that was that was
something I remember taking a class on
that uh when I was when I was in college
and I feel like I Still Still you know
try to use those skills to this day
where you know you're actually sitting
there in front of a person and you're
hearing what they say and you're
thinking about what they say instead of
figuring out what you're just going to
say next so so you know kind of having a
real active listening sort of um
conversation and then understanding that
you know
people are are people and uh we can be
inconsistent and hard to understand and
you know really all it takes is maybe a
little bit of openness and and kindness
to give space to the sorts of
conversations that need to happen you
know the sorts of kind of crucial
conversations that we have we call that
that's um kind of a a term that we use
at impo for these sort of intense
conversations that um need some sort of
resolution and and you know in my
opinion just just kind of being open to
that and uh understanding that you know
there's going to be some emotional
reactions and that's a okay because
we're all human beings um but it's
important to not you know just kind of
react to them and uh just fan the flames
you need to to figure out what sources
of the issue and address that love that
thank you Allan I see you have a
question here want to jump in yeah sure
hi um hey David I'm I'm really curious
um if so my instinct is a per like
performance metrics nuclear power is
really really specific like a super
specific domain um if that's the case I
wonder how that domain expertise comes
to play in the stuff you do day-to-day
or if maybe that's the wrong assumption
and really the metrics are around
efficiency and people metrics and like
things that are really familiar like I
wonder how specific what you're doing is
to um to that industry and and and you
know how you operate in that kind of
environment that that's an excellent
question so the um the industry metrics
we get we we get hundreds of data points
from every station every month and um we
use that to uh we end up you know
because every station can be a little
different you've got to you know go go
through some sort of you know kind of
like normalization scheme so we have
these indicators that are a way that we
normalize the data and then that's
that's what we can actually do some
modeling on um and I I have learned just
just how little I know about nuclear
power by moving to the industry side of
things and and needing to understand
exactly what you know every label every
acronym means and it it it will take a
really long time to get to that point
and luckily I don't need all of that to
do my day-to-day job but you know
whenever I'm um working on a really
important model I've got to make sure
that I'm not making some really bad
assumptions about it and so that that
you know means that I gotta sit down and
talk with my manager director or some
other other subject matter experts in
some of the functional areas here at Ino
just to kind of uh you know make make
sure that
whatever I don't know isn't gonna
actually bite me sometime so yeah that's
that's a great comment thanks and you
mentioned data science is relatively new
for impo um how have you been successful
in in introducing data science and data
science
tools great question
so you know introducing like a new tool
to to the Enterprise is a really
challenging thing you can't just you
know say here are some Model results and
expect everyone to understand what that
means so um one one of the um changes
that we've made and it's actually kind
of part of our governance that we've
we've written is that anytime there is
you know a new tool of some sort
delivered we have to uh figure out a way
to explain it or or interpret
it with some other you know some other
tool or maybe you know kind of a help
function of something sort so you know
one of the things that um we've learned
is that you know delivering these these
Model results that require some um
subtlety and understanding is is hard to
do for people that don't use it on a on
a real frequent basis so you know we've
added a lot more um kind of like help
functions into the tools that we we
build the way that we expose these Model
results and then we've also you know
kind of built some some other tools
to I got to talk generally to help you
understand why the model is saying what
it's saying and we've had a lot of
success and you know kind of thinking
about things from you know the the
enduser perspective and not at the data
science perspective to help us figure
out exactly what we can do better to um
to make sure that they use the tool
correctly and they get the Insight that
they want out of it I guess kind of
maybe this follows along with this a
little bit and no worries that there's
certain things you can't share with us
but there was an an anonymous question
that was what kind of data science use
cases can you share with us in the
nuclear industry and in your company
yeah so um you know what one I kind of
alluded to earlier is you know what kind
of the the impetus for data science that
impo is trying to understand performance
in between the uh the assessments every
two years biannual banal I never
remember the word um so uh you know we
we get data from the industry every
month and we have a model that uh helps
us gauge that sort of performance in
between the assessments right so so the
assessments are kind of our our gold
standard in the way that we know if the
model is right or wrong but uh it gives
us um an estimate in in between uh for
that for their
performance and then you know from there
uh there are other things where you can
you know maybe kind of come up with some
risk models to to see if uh something
you know has a high probability of
happening um and you know we don't
obviously don't want to H don't want it
to happen so we want to um figure out
that risk and try try to get ahead of it
um let's see what else we got I'm I'm
gonna stop there just you know just just
to make sure I keep it General enough
sorry that's okay when so when you share
those models who are you sharing them
with or how do you share a model with
broader stakeholder group
so um you know data science at Ino our
department is actually called data
science and it's composed of kind of
three groups so um one is data
visualization uh one is kind of data
analytics and that's that's where where
I live and then one is data quality or
data management I think we call it data
quality um so you know whenever I I
build a model you know I'm just kind of
having the results end up in a database
somewhere and then we rely on our
incredibly capable data visual
visualization group to actually kind of
build those visualizations to deliver it
to an end user so you know no no one
ever really gets those Raw results out
of the database they they get something
within a broader context to help them to
help make sure that they are
interpreting it correctly thank you sure
me jump over to one other anonymous
question first here and one was Pharma
has a huge emphasis on a very mod
concept of validation is there something
like this perception of regulatory
overhead that affects your work that
exists within the nuclear industry but
it doesn't affect Ino so um there is I
remember when when I worked it there's a
group called It's called nitel nitl The
Nuclear information technology and
strategic leadership group which is kind
of a a more nuclear it group working
group and they have um a focus on
quality assur
because there are very strict
regulations that go into um how you
validate that system that like a
software system is going to do what you
say it's going to do
um as long as you know it's going to do
what you say it's going to do and it's
going to work correctly and there
there's no way that it can kind of you
know get it wrong but that mostly
affects the the safety systems at a
nuclear stations as far as I understand
this is obvious you know not not my
wheelhouse um
but because we at Ino don't work
directly with you know kind of
supporting the safety system at a
nuclear power station we don't really
have to you know kind of go through that
very very rigorous process thank you um
George I think this question might be
kind of related but I saw you had a
question earlier about safety
assessments do you want to jump
in sure yeah um I was just curious you
know the the data that you're producing
and uh from the assessments is that ever
shared with other federal agencies and I
was thinking of Osha and um just been
thinking more about how similar to like
NOA Nordisk and their submissions to the
FDA you know um wondering if if you're
doing something like that for it even
possible we do um share you know some of
the content from the
reports let me make sure that I know the
one place that we share
um the the report I believe it's a
report but it's definitely the
assessment number the assessment score
is um the company
that issues out uh Insurance to the
nuclear power industry so
um our assessment score is directly
linked to uh nuclear station's insurance
rate which gives us a little bit of
uh it makes it very important that that
everything is right and uh that there
are uh you know kind of no no worries no
um challenges to it that that can't be
answered we share some um we call it
operating
experience with some other groups but I
don't think that we share the actual
Report with them so it's it's a very
kind of tightly you know guarded thing
that we share with the the senior
leadership at a station and um you know
we share at least the assessment number
with the the insurance group but for the
most part we kind of uh hold on to the
actual report findings um because there
there's a lot of ways that sharing that
can go
wrong sorry not not a gray
answer David I I I feel like this might
be a helpful conversation to open up
with the group but I know when you and I
were were chatting at posit conference
we were talking a bit about how when you
rolled out posit team it would have been
helpful to know what a bit more about
what some other teams were doing with
the products as well to also kind of get
ideas and share use cases with each
other um I don't know if you want to
expand on that a bit and maybe ask it to
the group too yeah heck yeah so so this
this is kind of my my my question for
the group is you know we we recently
rolled out posit
team and you know the the modeling work
that we've done at Ino has been a a very
particular kind of modeling work where
you know you kind of build build a big
model and you deliver some results and
then it gets sent to a visualization um
and that's that's mostly it uh but I
know that there is a lot more that um
you know like posit team and other
platforms offer a lot more capabilities
than that you know rather than just
building a model and putting results in
a
database and you know kind of coming
relatively new into this space it's been
hard to just kind of figure out you know
what what are the different ways to use
it like what are the things that I don't
know first and then what are what are
you know maybe the the best ways to
solve certain problems that that I do
know about you know so you know at a
real technical level you know we have uh
a lot of Microsoft SQL servers and you
know trying to um use those with posit
has some challenges so you know like
what what are the best ways to solve
that I know that posit has a lot of
really good documentation online but I'd
love to hear from from um people that
have actually solved this problem and
and you know kind of learn what they've
learned in the process if that makes
sense so like where where would someone
go to kind of learn these best practices
or have this sort of conversation
outside of you know a weekly data
science
hangout yes I see um Javier you put some
thoughts in the chat do you want to get
us going here I'm like mid chew with my
breakfast sorry sorry but I'll I'll
comment in a bit here
Okay who wants who else wants to jump in
then one of the things we had a lot of
success with um at a former life of mine
was we deployed reports and a lot of
these reports were were sort of meant to
monitor model scores over time and so um
this is not helping your Microsoft issue
I'm sorry but but but in terms of just
uh use cases in general um we would do
things like uh query in the back ends we
we could run report every day every week
perform a query bring in this new data
that we haven't seen yet um and then run
that through our models and then um get
some model scores and then we could
track those model scores compared to
yesterday's last week's whatever it is
and then uh we could use blastula to
send out alerts and we could essentially
create a custom report based on what we
were seeing and that could be sent out
to certain individuals associated with
the account in in question and sort of
thing so it's a nice handy monitoring
tool thanks I'm not I'm not chewing
anymore okay I could pop back in but
um yeah David I don't know if you're
using DB plier um oh yeah yeah okay so
you know about that um that's something
where I'm surprised how many R users at
my company don't know of DB plier um and
so they're like creating SQL files or
you know um
they're just doing things maybe in like
a 2010 view of the r World um and that's
okay because a lot of them are more like
you know proper statisticians who devops
and mlops isn't really something in
their wheelhouse um are you using well I
assume you're using some kind
of uh like get backed platform like
GitHub or or gitlab um something we've
recently been exploring with posit
connect um is just setting up a lot of
cicd pipelines to sort of um make the
whole deployment of content across
different um maybe like connect
instances so you've got different like
Dev or test or you know production
instances we're trying to sort
of create a process of um you know being
hands off like rolling up everything
through a lot of cicd and posit has like
excellent documentation on this stuff um
so if you're not doing that I definitely
recommend something like that too and it
plays nicely with you know tv player
also but yeah I guess like kind of even
even at a higher level so so we we have
this this platform know this this this
weekly hangout that we could use to you
know ask questions if it's the right
context but like where do y'all go
outside of this
to learn about the right ways to do
things or people's experienes way with
with different ways to do
things yeah for me personally I feel
like I'm asking questions all the time
in
public places internally at least I me I
say public like we have so many teams
channels around data and data quality
and data science and analytics and all
this stuff like I'm pretty Shameless
when it comes to asking a bunch of
questions on these things at the same
time like I'm I feel like I'm constantly
helping other people so it's like you
know there's give and take but
um I think for me it's a lot of just uh
like on the job exposure and
experience asking people stuff that
maybe I
wouldn't be able to ask publicly um and
just like working together
to you know get through some of these
hurdles I mean every every team has like
really unique challenges they might be
using R but they're like you know
they're trying to map to some network
drive or something and it's like well we
can't really do that or not as easily
but they want to fix so it's like you
know I don't know sorry I feel like I'm
hijacking the conversation here
he what you think but like internal
networking I guess is what I would
summarize my comments to that's really
helped a lot for
us and I think Katherine from my company
is on here too I don't know if she has
any additional Javier is totally
Shameless about asking tons of questions
and and everything um but I do think
that you're right in asking about like
where do you go to get how best
practices because internally your team
had like or your company has a way that
they do things um so getting exposure to
the ways that other companies do things
like knowing what else is out there can
be really difficult
um I don't personally do too much
research because I try to like not work
outside of work
um but it does make it it does make it
difficult to figure out like what else
is out there to then come back to those
conversations if you're setting up data
scientists it or those kinds of
conversations to bring those ideas if
you don't know what they
are yeah I don't know what I don't
know yeah and I and I know some industry
groups like Pharma have their own like
are in Pharma organizations as well to
share things with each other but um I
think a great option too is like meeting
each other from within this group too
and having like smaller conversations or
one-off conversations I know some people
have gotten to make friends from the
data science Hangouts too so encouraging
I encourage people to like connect with
each other on LinkedIn too and feel free
to to share your your LinkedIn in the
chat too if you do want to connect with
others um but I I feel like I I should
say this here too some something I've
been thinking about is if there are
certain topics that come up in a forum
like this where we maybe want to dive
deeper into it could we have like a
smaller group conversation following it
maybe it's on a specific topic like I
don't know securing packages or having
the conversation with it about using
open source packages or maybe it's about
shiny in production or something like
that um so I'll think I'll think a bit
more on that as
well yeah the challenge for us is you
know um we're we we at Ino are pretty
new to this so there there there isn't
that sort of kind of institutional
knowledge that that we can um qu you
know reach out and and question other
people about it so it's at this point
you know either you know kind of talking
to to other people in the nuclear
industry and we do have um a data
science Industry working group that
we've um set up um at Ino but across the
nuclear industry and we've we're
starting to get some good traction with
that but even even past that you know
it's good to have conversations with
people of different you know in
different Industries just to kind of
understand you know how they might think
about things differently absolutely um
Justin I see you had a question a bit
earlier Justin Lee do you want to jump
in yes I am looking back to see what my
question was no worries I can ask your
question if you want to add context too
but
please the question was speaking
generally how is the industry beginning
to use natural language
processing okay
um tell you uh the little that I know so
I know that um some places have set up
you know their own private instances of
of chat GPT because uh you know Nu
nuclear data is is regulated tightly
regulated uh so you have to be really
careful about what infrastructure it
lives on um so generally speaking we're
going to want to keep things on Priss uh
you know in our own domains rather than
use something on on Azure or AWS if if
we we can so uh people have set up
private instances of chat gbt to try to
kind of understand how how it could be
used for their organizations uh and
there there has been you know kind of
some success but as you all probably
know not everything that comes out of
chat GPT is correct even if it sounds
like a good well formed sentence um so
there's that and then you know a lot
there's a lot of interest in um trying
to figure out how to look at
at this this is a pretty well-known kind
of program across stations so I don't
think it's wrong to talk about it so uh
stations have something called a
corrective Action Program so um you know
kind of generally speaking anytime um
there is an event something goes wrong
whether that's someone you know tripping
on the sidewalk walking into the station
or there's a reactor scram there there
is um a report written up about that and
you know for uh a single unit station I
think there's probably 600 people
working there and um that means there
are a lot of these reports that get
written and you know at a certain point
you have a whole lot of Text data and
not enough people or the right
technology to actually kind of trend it
and track it well so there's a lot of
interest right now in understanding how
to use this kind of history of of cap
records to uh understand you know kind
of U the behaviors that might influence
performance so those are the two kind of
big use cases I've heard so
far that makes sense thank
you thank
you um another question I think I maybe
saw earlier maybe something Anonymous as
well
um what actually let me shift gears for
a second I know when we were we were
chatting before you were talking a
little bit about how you're hiring for a
role and I thought it might be good to
just discuss a little bit of what you've
learned recently in trying to fill a
data science role too it is uh it's
challenging as a lot of you probably
know so we did actually fill the role
the person hasn't started yet but you
know kind of everything's everything's
been been signed so um we're good there
and and I feel like I learned a lot
about what it takes to hire a data
scientist in that process so um you know
we
we found that we got a lot of success
using um recruiters versus just kind of
having an open job posting just because
the the market is pretty well flooded
and we wanted someone that had some
particular natural language uh
experience so you know instead of going
through the the mountain of of resumés
it was a little bit easier to uh to have
people help us find you know people who
were looking and people who had the
right sort of resume and then from there
you know going through the the technical
screen to make sure that they had the
the
right the right understanding that we
were looking for um and then you know so
so that wasn't wasn't too bad but you
know trying to trying to find the right
especially
when I don't know enough about natural
language processing to to to put it on
my resume but I'm trying to hire people
who have that experience you know you
you've got to do enough research so that
you can ask the right questions and um
that was um I mean that was pretty
interesting that was a lot of fun to be
honest with you um but it was surprising
to figure out exactly what you know in
the process what you needed to look for
on a resume to to get the right level of
experience because you know having some
some Spacey or some hugging face
experience doesn't necessarily mean that
you were right for the role and um the
thing that I think surprised me most was
that when we started looking for people
who didn't just have like a master's
degree in data science or analytics but
we're looking for um things that were
kind of more um like applied roles where
you you were M you know U getting a
masters in or PhD in something besides
those you know particular Fields but you
had to use machine learning data science
NLP in order to actually uh achieve that
that PhD or that
Masters there was a lot of I found those
conversations to be you know
surprisingly useful because you know
this person is not
just I went through um a master's
program and got a masters in analytics
and you know for the for the the
Capstone it was like okay you get to
figure out how to put all of this
together and then uh do it on your own
and figure it out you know you took all
these classes and you get to figure it
out and um people with kind of what what
I'm calling an applied perspective for
data science have already been able to
do that and it's just uh it was it was
really U useful to you know kind of sus
that out in the process so that that's
something I'd recommend is is look you
know maybe uh
expanding the pool of applicants past
just those those people that have the
the master's degrees in in analytics and
data science that I think you know we
probably all have seen them or have
those
ourselves yeah did you so did you end up
redesigning the job description of
it no we
we we just ended it up um taking a while
to find the right
candidate Ben I see you just put a a
question in the chat want to jump in
yeah hey David thanks for the time what
are you currently working on to build
your skill set um I'm thinking more on
the technical side obviously you're
doing a lot on the soft skills but what
are some maybe historical uh stuff that
that has been in your industry or some
other things outside of your industry
that you're working on that's going to
advance skill set you find interesting
maybe so um I got to learn about law
about I got to learn a lot about Linux
so tongue twister uh because I was the
one that got to do the posit install
earlier this year so that was um
interesting challenging um I know a lot
more about infrastructure than I ever
did now and I'll file that away for a
rainy day on the um data science side of
things you know I am um you know where's
where's my book I'm I'm reading through
Max's book Applied Predictive modeling
right and just trying to you know kind
of wrap my head
around things dealing you know the the
different sorts of of models and and
approaches to you know maybe kind of
cross
validation statistical machine learning
that we'll need because we we tend to
use kind of smaller data sets at impo so
it's you know we don't have anything
that I would call like Big Data at the
moment um so it's it's a very particular
kind of flavor of of data science and
machine learning so I am uh reading
through that and then just trying to
figure out different ways to actually
stay up to date with you know new new
models new algorithms finding the right
papers to read to to stay up to date
with those sorts of advances and I
haven't really found a great place that
kind of centralizes all that information
yet so if anybody else has some ideas
about where to look I think I learned
about our weekly at positon this year so
um yeah feel free to share that because
I'm I've got an appetite for it I um I
was just saying I see a lot of Great
Links shared in the chat too so I'll
take those and consolidate them and
share with you as well David thank you
that's excellent um an an anonymous
question from a bit earlier was what are
the biggest challenges you face when
putting data science Solutions in
production
so I mean to be honest we haven't faced
a whole lot of that yet because we are
still pretty pretty fresh you know my my
brain goes back to the way that we um
created uh a model that you know kind of
estimates performance in between
evaluations and uh deliver those results
but because that model is is such a kind
of a tightly guarded secret you know I I
I consider it probably the most critical
piece of intellectual property we have
at Eno because you know if anyone finds
what goes into that model then um you
know then there's no way to build a
better
model so um delivering those results
meant that we can't tell people what you
know what goes into the model which
means that you know when a station's
value changes they of course want to
know why that's just a natural thing to
to to ask and we didn't really give
people a great way to explain that you
know at a at a kind of a general level
so um last year we built a tool to help
them kind of interpret that score and
the the changes to that score and you
know every time we would build this
model we'd get this this this mountain
of emails asking why this and that
changed and then we uh built this tool
that helps give context to the changes
and you know now it's kind of crickets
every time we publish the model results
which is you know good news for
everyone past that um you know we're
going to be building more kind of tools
models apis um but we haven't done it
yet so I'm not really sure what the
Challen challenges are right so you know
if anyone has any uh Lessons Learned I'm
I'm I'm so ready and willing to to hear
what yall have learned as part of you
know kind of pushing out posit team or
any other sort of data science platform
yeah and and David if people do want to
connect directly after is LinkedIn the
best way yeah yeah okay I'll share your
chat here in a second too but um Nick I
see you just asked a question in the
chat want to jump in here next hi sure
hi everyone so basically I'm trying to
relate to something I'm currently going
through at work where we just set up a
kind of an analytics team and before the
business is willing to really commit any
resources and invest we keep getting
this um ask to estimate the ROI we
expect from the project before the
business is willing to commit any time
or resources to help us with it and
basically I'd like to ask you for ideas
around how do you approach estimating
the ROI from a project before you even
you know really have the resources or
the Buy in to start looking into it and
followup question once a project is
implemented how do you look back and
estimate the ROI from a project you've
implemented already so this is a really
challenging question to ask because we
we are a nonprofit with a mission to uh
you know kind of make sure that the the
industry performs at the highest
standards of excellence that we can set
um so you know coming up with an Roi
it's it's really hard to quantify that
and and we have different ways that we
do that but I I don't really maybe think
that they're more generally applicable
to to what you're talking about um you
know kind of from a pure project
management
standpoint ideally I feel like what you
would want to do is is
uh you know put
together ah I was going to try to to
answer it well but I I I don't have a
good answer for you yeah it's it's just
it's not something that we deal with um
in the same way that I think that you do
and I don't feel like I've got a good
answer for you I from um I could share
one from another hangout we had with
Natalie O'Shea at at better up um I was
trying to find the little clip to share
with you but Natalie shared a bit how
when she was going through this process
for getting approval for posit team she
focused in on one's specific problem
that the team had and
so uh the use case she gave was their
their Consulting organization so their
sales team had to make these PowerPoints
over and over again with new data and
based on different Industries and to
actually make a great deck for a
presentation was taking hours and hours
and
so they sent out a poll to all of the
sales reps to ask how much time were
they taking building these and they
actually put a dollar amount to it and
so I think it ended up being like $ 1.2
million a year in in people cost um and
then she showed how she could automate
that with a shiny application that the
sales team would go to the shiny app
kind of put in whatever they needed for
the customer and then automatically
generate the PowerPoint which was tied
to the directly to their database as
well and so and using that one example
she was able to put a dollar amount to
it so maybe that's one tip is to think
in your when you're building this
business case to think about one team
that you might be able to help um
because then they might be the ones kind
of joining on to your business case too
like I think it was maybe the head of
sales that ended up helping Push It
Forward for their data team too yeah I
think that's very useful inside actually
Rachel thanks for that only thing is
that I think when it comes to automation
of daily routine task and activities it
a bit easier to estimate R away as
opposed to you know analytics modeling
where you're dealing with uncertainty
right and sometimes you're not even sure
if you get anywhere with the time you
invest right so yeah it's not an easy
task and I would really appreciate any
thoughts or feedback from anyone that's
gone through that experience before as
well
Trace Nick um this is Eduardo Castillo
and I uh actually I'm from the nuclear
industry I know Dave we we're a working
group at impo and and one thing I can
offer from a data science perspective is
that um it's important to kind of go for
big targets uh so one of the big
projects we're working on right now is
around reducing diving frequencies for
cleaning some of our intake structures
and that's a very big you know $1
million year project where we had no
ongoing data science efforts to uh
improve performance of that uh that
Evolution and so having a big Target I
think was important because even if we
could cut you know 5% of that it becomes
a good hard hard dollar dollar Roi and
the second piece is um looking at at
things like Risk like when you have like
an activity like diving you do have a
lot of Occupational risk and we're
actually able to tie you know what um
what the occupational risk is and how it
compares to other activities that we do
at the plant so it allows us to kind of
capture both the part savings and also
the qualitative software savings and and
again just starting with a big Target a
project that uh you know is targeting a
big budget I think it's important
thanks adoria yeah thanks so much
anybody else want to jump in on this
topic I Laura I see you unmuted do you
want to add something yeah I can't find
the button um yeah I was just wna for
the idea about Roi um there's a podcast
called cdio Matters by a guy Malcolm
Hawker he works at prophecy um with
doing MDM um and he's got I listen to
his podcast while running it's a great
like intellectual thing um but has has a
lot of information about Roi um
especially in light of you see a lot of
these press releases about data teams
being laid off and you know those of us
in data are like how can you do that um
you know data is so important but again
it's that proof that you're actually
impacting the bottom line of the company
and so if you want to dig a little more
into that World um I highly recommend
his podcasts um they're not they're not
too overly fluffy with crap um and
they're all they're all quite
interesting about 45 minutes um so high
highly recommend if if that idea of Roi
is important absolutely yeah I think you
you shared the link maybe in the chat
too I go okay um is thanks for the
recommendation Abigail do you w to add
anything here I saw your comment in the
chat too oh sorry yeah it feel free to
just raise your hand on here if anybody
has anything else to to add but I'll try
and jump over to some of the remaining
questions too um um let's see we had
quite a few anonymous questions I want
to make sure I didn't miss anything so
but when we get to the last few minutes
here if there's something you asked that
you that didn't get answered as well
feel free to recopy it into the zoom
chat
here um but one of the other
questions David
was what is your company's relationship
as relates to the interface between
government and
Industry so so um that that's great so
so there's the NRC which is you know
kind of the government regulator and and
they have all of their their own
guidelines they do their own sorts of
evaluations but the you know kind of the
the whole impetus of Ino was was when
Three Mile Island happened there was
this uh Jimmy Carter put together this
commission it was called the Kime
commission and um the commission you
know had a whole lot of findings one of
them was that there needed to be kind of
an independent non-governmental
organization to set these sorts of uh
safety and reliability standards and
then to assess them so um we we are uh
not really I mean we we're in the
nuclear industry so of course we're
associated with the NRC but uh we don't
really uh answer to them you know we we
kind of answer more so to to our members
to the domestic nuclear industry so
we're we're two sort of kind of
regulatory bodies that have you know
maybe some some different some some
overlapping but also um some you know
kind of different different missions
thank
you um so a question that I love to get
to ask everybody towards the end
is is there a piece of career advice
that stands out to you whether it's been
something that you've received or advice
you've given that you'd like to share
with
us um I knew you were G to ask this so I
I had to think about it in advance and I
I had like like five or six different
things that I came up with the the one
that I think I want to stick with is uh
be open to doing things that make you
feel
uncomfortable so I you know as as a
human being but also professionally you
know that's kind of where the the growth
happens you know if you just do the same
thing day in day out you're just going
to kind of you know uh tread water in in
a way but uh if you you know lean into
the things that make you uncomfortable
in a healthy way obviously then uh I
think that's you know kind of that's
where you can grow your uh you know
your your your profession professional
relationships your your technical
capabilities like your mental health in
a way is is kind of you know leaning
into that and uh being okay with the
discomfort knowing that uh you know
you're going to learn something from it
so like can you share an example with us
of where you're you're doing that being
asked to do a data science
hangout yes
awesome yeah
yeah and the the other piece um and I've
been a part of them for for seven years
is Toast Masters it's something you know
working on your communication skills is
is critical as a data scientist you know
you can you can create the coolest
coolest you know uh model next big um
app that sort of thing but if you can't
really communicate it well then uh it's
you're going to have a a hard time um
getting other people to understand why
it's so important so um figuring out
ways to to kind of hone those skills are
are really really important just as much
in my opinion as kind of the technical
skills definitely um Y and I I see you
had asked a question in the chat want to
jump in here oh yes I time when I listen
to some great talk I would like the
speaker to share some good
books good books you like not maybe uh
definitely yeah I love the books a the
sense books but any other books you want
to share I mean because I'm wor us said
is so smart and
wise that's that's that's funny um I'm
looking at at my bookshelf to see you
know what kind of Pops off pops into my
head you know um the I'm not I'm not
employed by pit but they they do you
know people that work for posit have
some pretty good books are for data
science and then also um you know kind
of the the elements of statistical
learning that was one of the the books
that I ended up buying as part of my
graduate program that I still refer to
to this day um you know outside of that
um I picked up a book called on being
nice uh this past weekend that I I
really really enjoy and you know kind of
kind of you know sits well with me and
then there's also a book that um started
reading called Focus that's really
really interesting but you know the
these are just kind of things that are
off the top of my head I can't really
think of anything else major but um I I
I'd love for for people to maybe type
into the chat any books that you might
recommend um whether they're you know
related to data science or not I see
that I like to
know does anybody have Libby's uh link
handy she's been keeping track of all
the books recommended in the The
Hangout that's fun oh I don't know I'm
being a bad multitasker today trying to
go find it so if anybody can sh can
share it that would be
great um
I see there's a thank you I see there's
a bit of a um kind of sub conversation
happening in the chat to when we were
talking about maybe uh these smaller
group chats too and perhaps having one
like a whole discussion on RI might be a
useful one so I will save this chat here
so I can reach out to everybody but in
that thread if you want to just put your
email in there um I'll say right here I
will save that and reach out so we can
maybe schedule a separate chat around
Roi too awesome so let's see any for any
questions that have gone unanswered does
anybody want to raise your hand here and
jump in and ask it I think we
have think we've covered everything oh
Michael there you go so I if I can still
assess the um information in the chat
because I I do not want to lose them
I've missed some so I still want to get
back to them yes definitely so if you
want to save the info in the chat you
can use the three dots below it where it
says
more and then you can press save chat
there um but David I guess to end on a
note of I don't I think the
function i c if you wanna Michael if you
want to send me share your email in the
chat I can email it to you as well if it
doesn't work for you um um but David one
other question I I'd love to ask is
thinking about the year ahead 2024
what's something that you're excited
about for your team so
so this this year was kind of focused on
on building out what we call our data
science environment getting posit built
and now it's it's built it's stable and
and we're ready to use it and I'm just
excited to try to figure out all the the
different ways that we could deliver
these really incredible data science
products to you know kind of so the
industry at large and then also to to
Ino internally it's just um it's
something that we've never really had
and really really excited to uh I don't
know to put it to good use awesome well
thank you so much David for joining us
today and thank you all for all the
great questions and spending your
Thursday with us I'm trying to get
better about saying this but I talk to a
lot of people from companies who might
not know that other teams within their
company are using our tools so if you
are ever just curious and want to chat
with us about it I made a little like
form for myself so that it was in one
place so feel free to put your name
there and I'm happy to connect you with
others within your your company
too um but thank you again for for
spending time with us today appre really
appreciate it David thank you thank you
Rachel thank you David thank you
everyone byebye bye everybody thank
you